events leading to Hanukkah. Do you know
the history of Hanukkah? By the way,
you're going to be celebrating Hanukkah
this month with Christmas.
>> I'm not super familiar. Uh
>> commemorates the event. In the year 167
BC, December
167 BC, a pagan ruler named Antiochus,
Antiocus,
Epi, Fenis, Epifus I, however you want
to pronounce it. Epi fis or Epifus I
fork, a pagan ruler who ruled in Syria
entered Jerusalem, thousands of Jews,
forced the Jews to stop sacrificing to
God and forced them to stop obeying the
law of Moses and would kill anyone who
continued to do so. And then he
desecrated the temple by slaughtering a
pig on the altar and building an altar
to Zeus to defy the god of the Jews.
When did he do this? December
167 BC.
>> Okay. God stirred up a family
Mcabes
to lead a revolt to raise up an army
trusting in the power of God to defeat
the larger pagan army by the power of
God.
So this is where you get Mcabes. Judas
Mcabes, the Makabian family, the
Makabian revolt. Judas the leader
raised up an army trusting in God to
give them the victory to then destroy
Antiochus's army and reclaim the temple
which they did. Now remember when did he
defile the temple? December 167 BC.
[clears throat] They then reclaimed the
temple on December 25th, 165 BC. Judas
Mcabes, that's why it's called the book
of Mcabes.
>> Mhm.
>> It's named after the family. Judas
Mcabes led an army, a small Jewish army,
trusting in God to give them the power
to defeat the larger pagan army. And
they did miraculously. It was a miracle
of God.
>> Mhm. They defeated the pagan army, drove
them out, reclaimed the temple to God.
You know what the date was
when they reclaimed the temple?
>> Um,
>> it wasn't December 167. I gave another
date.
>> Let me think.
>> No, I'm not. I can't recall the date.
>> December December 25th, 165 BC. Do you
know what BC is? before Christ.
>> Okay. What's the date they reclaimed the
temple?
>> 165.
>> 16. Uh 165.
>> But what's the month?
>> December. December
>> only. I said December what?
>> 25th.
>> You got it. You still significance of
December 25th.
>> Be Christmas, too, right?
>> You got it. See, that's why I want you
to get it.
>> Yep.
They reclaimed the temple to God
December 25th, the date that was later
chosen to celebrate the birth of Jesus
Christ, who's God in the flesh. Because
Jesus's flesh body becomes the temple of
God. This why I wanted you to get the
date.
>> Oh wow.
>> See?
>> Wow. I did not know there was even any
connection.
>> Yes, there is. Hanukkah is connected
with Jesus.
>> December 25th, 165 BC. Okay.
>> They reclaimed the temple. The temple is
where God dwells with his people.
>> Mhm.
>> But why is this significant? Because
Jesus when he became flesh, he became
man. He made his physical body the
temple of God. That's why he says in
John 2 19 and 22, "Destroy this temple
and I will raise it up in three days."
[clears throat]
>> And they said, "It's taken 46 years to
build the temple." Because they thought
he's talking about the temple in
Jerusalem. Right. Right?
>> They didn't know he's talking about his
body and you're going to raise it up in
three days. Then John said, "But the
temple he was speaking about was his
body." So did you see that Jesus said,
"My physical body is the temple where
God dwells in all his fullness."
>> Mhm.
>> And that physical body that became God's
temple, he took from Mary, right, as he
was being conceived in Mary.
>> Mhm.
And when he was born, now you have a
baby born and that physical body of that
physical male child is now the physical
temple where God dwells in all his
fullness.
>> Right?
>> And you see why then we celebrate
December 25th because Anuka
commenced December 25th, 165 BC where
the temple of God was rededicated to God
and cleansed of its pagan defilement.
And the temple becomes a picture of
Christ's physical body, which becomes
the true everlasting temple of God.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah, that's really deep.
>> I want to show you where I got the date
because you're going to see we're going
to go with purgatory. Just
you okay, man?
>> Daniel 8:14,
New English Translation, footnote.
Daniel 8:14 gives you the historical
background concerning Daniel's
prophecies that were announcing the
future. And part of that annunciation
was Daniel saw Antiochus arising to
defile the temple and slaughtering the
saints of God. God already revealed to
Daniel
several hundred years of history before
it happened and he recorded it. So now a
good Bible commentary will give you the
historical information so you can see
what Daniel was referring to and when
was it fulfilled. So now when I go here,
watch here.
>> Daniel 8:14 talking about Hanukkah when
Antus was defeated and destroyed.
When was he defeated and destroyed?
Never mind. I'll find someone like you.
What happened here, dude? Daniel 8.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> Sorry about that, brother. Because it's
uh I went to the wrong here. There's a
channel. You ready? Yep.
>> Here you go. Daniel 8:14.
This prophecy
that pointed to the future. Now, this
the footnotes going to tell you when it
was fulfilled. It was fulfilled when
Antiochus came and defiled the temple
and stopped them from sacrificing. Now,
watch here. Here's the note.
The language of evenings and mornings.
Dan 8:14 the prophecy is reminiscent of
the creation account in Genesis 1. There
was evening, there was morning, day one.
There was evening, there was morning,
day two. Since evening, morning is
equivalent of a day. The reference here
would be to 2,300 days. So God told
Daniel 2,300 days, right?
>> Mhm.
>> Where something's going to happen. Now
they're telling you what happened during
those days and when it was fulfilled.
But you don't need to remember that.
What I want you to remember is the
commencement. When does those days end?
See, as the cat bothers me. However,
some interpreters understand the
reference
here, right? To be to the evening
sacrifice and morning sacrifice, in
which case the reference would be to
only 1,150 days. So they're they're
debating is it 2,300 days or 1,150 days.
They they're not certain. Either way,
the event that marked the commencement
of the spirit isn't clear. We can't tell
you when these days began, but we can
tell you when it ended. So when did it
end? Are you listening?
>> Yes.
>> When did the prophecy end? Here it is.
>> The event that marked the conclusion.
Joshua, you listening to
>> Joshua? I'm fighting with pizza.
>> Oh my gosh. He's always
>> I've had a I had an early morning, so
I'm fighting to stay awake.
>> All right. So, okay. Why don't you get
some beauty sleep then? No. You
listening?
>> I'm
>> the conclusion of the period. When was
the prophecy fulfilled? When did the
days end? The conclusion
was the red dedication of the temple in
Jerusalem [clears throat]
following the atrocious and sacriicious
acts that Antiochus implemented. So when
did they reclaim the temple? This took
place on December 25th,
165 BC.
>> Yes. Yep. Wow.
>> The Jewish celebration of Hanukkah each
year commemorates his victory. So you
know what Hanukkah is?
I don't know what the I don't know the
translation now.
>> Hanukkah means dedication.
>> Okay.
>> This is the feast of dedication. What
were they dedicating?
>> The new temple, right? I mean the
reclamation.
>> They were dedicating the temple back to
God because it had been defiled, right?
>> Yes.
>> Now, do you see why the Jews every
December celebrate Hanukkah, the eight
days of Hanukkah?
>> Yeah. Yeah. But they don't but they
don't believe that. I mean the Jews
today aren't celebrating Jesus at all.
>> But that has nothing to do Hanukkah has
nothing to do with Jesus for them.
Hanukkah is what
>> then? What is Hanukkah?
>> They don't even have a temple anymore
though at this point.
>> Yeah. But brother, don't let me throw
myself off the first floor.
>> Do they still celebrate Hanukkah? Do I
have to show you?
>> No, they do. Yes, you're right.
>> But uh you're poor white.
>> Not the sho strings.
>> Yeah, I'm about to hang myself. My sho
string. You're poor white.
>> Oh no. Greater is the reward for the
sacrifice of having to repeat yourself
10,000 times. [laughter]
Lord preserve all of you. Okay. So,
brother, without a temple, do they still
celebrate Hanukkah? The eight days of
Hanukkah?
>> They do.
>> Don't you see the Hanukkah lights?
>> I see them sometimes. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, they still celebrate Hanukkah
to this day without a temple. Now, did
you know Jesus celebrated Hanukkah?
[clears throat]
Yeah, I could I could see back then he
would probably do it.
>> But you're told in the gospel he did.
Not probably.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> There you go.
>> Hate that.
>> Jesus celebrated Hanukkah. Mr. John
10:22-23.
Then came the feast of the dedication
Jerusalem. It was winter and Jesus was
walking in the temple area in Solomon's
portico. Notice it even tells you it
takes place in winter. Mhm.
>> And who was there in Jerusalem walking
in the temple?
>> Jesus.
>> And the feast of dedication, here's the
note, that is Hanukkah,
festival of lights.
>> Okay.
>> So Jesus celebrated Hanukkah.
>> We got it. And yes.